i got the chords if if y'all got the
votes
sure hit me
[Music]
ground control to major tom
welcome to the corridor cast today
we've got a cool thing to talk about
because
it's luke skywalker yeah why aren't you
playing the star wars theme peter
oh i used to know it dude welcome back
everyone to another episode of the
corridor cast and today we're going to
be talking about
deep fakes and the mandalorian more
specifically
spoiler alert for you know mandalorian
season two we're gonna be talking a lot
about luke skywalker
uh if you are a fan of the podcast and
tune in regularly
hey guess what you get a sneak peek at
the content coming out this weekend
however if you are coming from the whole
weekend of luke skywalker stuff
welcome to the corner cast we like to
talk about stuff
and that's what we're going to do about
today yeah i feel like we've got some
new listeners on this one because we
we mentioned that we have a podcast in a
vfx artist react video some new true
tones
some new true topics that's right
croutons the truest of croutons
c-r-e-w-t-o-n-s so one of the limiting
things of vfx artists react is that we
cover like anywhere between three and
like six
different movies or clips really scenes
and so we don't and the videos are
usually around 15 minutes or so so we
usually don't have that much time to
really dive into the details and the
nitty-gritty
of how they work but in this episode we
got an hour to talk about stuff
we usually film for like three hours too
for vfx artists i know right
like we filmed for three hours to get
that 15 minutes of gold
yeah that's so much editing it is i mean
it's the hardest part of
the whole show is just editing yeah
it takes a whole week the one thing that
like always gets me is like somebody
leave a comment like
they didn't mention that one thing and
it's like oh we did mention that one
thing i know i get that too
it's like i can't believe i can't
believe you guys didn't like talk about
this thing i was like
i spent 10 minutes talking about it and
then dean's like nah not interesting
the whole thing like dang it dean you
know what you can't argue with the
editor i know it's
they they have a good eye and ear for
you know one is dragon
what's entertaining what's actually
pushing some sort of story
or when there's a dragon in the shot yes
so star wars am i right star wars so
yeah mandalorian season two um pretty
good yeah it's
it's not bad there's a couple episodes
that were
one episode in particular that i didn't
like at all but several of the episodes
i thought were like
literal filming like masterpieces like
episode was like oh my god wait which
one was that
uh episode five four the ice cave one no
no no no no not the
other jedi with the two white
lightsabers oh yeah that one was sweet
yeah yeah
okay but every freaking cinema sarcastic
what
are you doing no it was great okay every
freaking cinematic universe has created
like
some metal uh type of metal that's like
indestructible you got
vibranium you got uh unobtainium
you got what's the mandalorian one
mental uranium it's this new trope and
i'm tired of it
atm yeah star wanium star wars
titanium i'm done so okay so episode
eight i think of the mandalorian the
final episode of the season
all the heroes are down on their luck
they're begging for food on the corners
says
a bunch of killer robots which are the
peak
technology and star wars at the time
robots
uh coming to kill them and take their
jobs yes i'm paraphrasing the show
and and then of course luke skywalker
comes flying in on his x-wing to save
the day and honestly i thought that
whole sequence where he was just
laying waste all of them i thought that
was pretty cool i was so excited i
thought it was i liked it better than
the vader scene from
rogue one really i like that much better
that vader scene is way better
like intense like in intensity
it had more pizzazz i think but it was
so short you know it was over in like
literally 28 seconds
i mean it's an emotional moment though
like seeing luke skywalker come back
like i don't care like i'm a jaded star
wars fan at this point most people are i
feel like
but like luke skywalker got me you know
it's a big part of my childhood and it's
a big part of why i'm even here in this
room like
you know recording this podcast why
anybody's even listening to me it's like
it's because of those movies
most like babies first vfx shot oh
yeah every day for six weeks did
lightsabers in photoshop
good wow
dude that's like the same as me i don't
use photoshop i just use after effects
i use this video editing program to edit
my photos there are a surprising amount
of vfx artists who use after effects to
edit photos it's a real thing i've i've
since learned i'm not alone
oh yeah so luke skywalker shows up
it takes his hood off because he had hit
his face through the whole action scene
and you know when his hood came off i
was like damn that looks pretty good
i thought the same thing i was like
because i actually kind of knew going
into it because everyone messaged me
like
you got to react to luke skywalker from
the mandalorian i'm like what
it is it's friday morning the episode
came out
hours ago these were people like
literally waited until midnight
thursday night to watch the episode and
immediately spoil it for me online i was
like
dude that's the curse you have as a
reacting vfx artist i know i know
and it wasn't that big of a deal but the
point is that i knew to expect luke at
the end of this i knew that was luke the
moment like his x-wing showed up so i
was like okay
i was i was ready to judge how he looked
and my first reaction was
all right yeah all right not bad at
first glance it looks pretty damn good
yeah because
he's not doing anything the moment
it like it gets a little closer and he
starts actually like performing at all
that was when i was like oh okay okay
that's why it looks good
yeah like specifically when he talks
he's got a very stiff lip
yeah um and yeah like that first shot
when he takes the thing off
his hood off his head i was like okay
not bad like they did a good job like
aging him up a little bit and giving him
a slightly new look that stays true to
him and then like
it had the grit and the detail and the i
guess what makes it look human
it wasn't moving it looked really good
yeah the lighting and the skin tone and
the texture were spot-on it was just the
animation
yeah and you know it should be worth
like we should mention this
so the hardest thing to do in cg
well i mean the hardest thing to do is
to rotoscope a tree that's out of focus
in front of your acting
bush anyone who's not an effects artist
will have no idea what that means
but this is the absolute truth oh my god
3d conversion artists
yeah i'm so sorry oh boy all right
second hardest thing slash the actual
hardest thing in cg
is to make a digital human being well
you can make a digital human being the
hard part is making it look real
like we've been doing that like that is
the holy grail of visual effects
the closest we've gotten is gemini man i
mean once again
60 70 of the movie it doesn't look real
well maybe 50 but there's parts that do
look flawless
and they actually have shots where both
dudes like the
old and young will smith were both 100
cg what i didn't realize it until after
i watched it
why i don't know why
i guess ain't lee shot the whole thing
in like true stereoscopic 120 frames per
second
and then they're like oh we can totally
tell the actors aren't punching each
other
because we can see depth in our shots
you can't stack punches
and we have such high frame rates that
you can tell that
the reactions don't line up so they're
just like i guess we'll do
the whole thing in cg that's ridiculous
it's so bad
i would argue that another like perfect
uh cg human is in logan when
the wolverine yeah yes it's just like
i was blown away that sounds like
different than agent smith from
the matrix series like it's just the cg
head on a dude
it is as far as the technology is the
same same thing with
uh what's your face from blade runner 20
49 yeah they are still computer
generated heads
necks skin rendering hair rendering eye
rendering all that stuff
is generated with intention behind it
and animated um
and yeah i honestly that was literally
the thesis of my
of my vfx what was the thing
yeah a ted talk yeah my test talk that i
did the tedx
talk at u-pen was it was literally about
how like this stuff isn't just a matter
of
you know pressing a button it takes a
lot of care and specifically
the hardest thing to do is a human face
and make it realistic because
you can get it to 99.9 good and it's
still not enough
yeah so it has to be 100 yeah because
we've spent millions of years evolving
by recognizing each other's faces
anything that's off is immediately like
i can tell
it's the whole 80 20 rule too it takes
20 of your time to get 80
of the way there it takes 80 percent of
your time to get the rest of the 20
percent
yeah or in this case it's the the point
one percent
of the work takes 99.9 of the time
yeah so you know the big thing though is
that these humans that have looked good
the one in logan the one in blade runner
they're they're not performing they're
just
they're very hot like they're basically
wax models at that point you know
um although i went back and watched some
of the weapon x i think was his name
in logan and he's mostly obscured by
action so moving camera motion blur
there are a few times when he is like
pinned down and he's like snarling
like this and it looks very good yeah
but we always only remember that one
shot where he's coming down the stairs
because that was the one they put
all of their time and resources that was
that was the money shot you know that
was like
all right you got it you gotta have one
shot that looks good this is the one
yeah so i mean what makes human head so
hard to do
in cgi outside the fact that we are
biologically wired to identify a single
thing being wrong with them
is that you have a lot of crazy physics
simulations going on on the human head
well one you have thousands and
thousands of hairs
over the whole thing which are all
slightly translucent so
already you're dealing with crazy
physics of hairs and crazy physics of
light
you're also dealing with uh rigid body
dynamics aka
your skeleton and then you have soft
body dynamics on top of that which is
basically all your flesh and your skin
and it's different
densities of soft bodies and technically
even fluid dynamics
because there's water in your eyes and
in your mouth
so the whole thing gets really
complicated because even like if you're
watching
this podcast with video like on you on
the youtube channel when i talk my head
moves
it's moving because my job moves it just
moves because my chest moves it moves
because the hands move like
it's all attached like you can spend all
your time animating ahead but if you
haven't even thought about the hands
well then what's the head motion
gonna be based on like my hands move my
head my feet move my
my hands like my whole body's connected
so you're sitting there like as an
artist who specializes in face
animations
and it's like well but are you getting
your physics right for your hand
animations
do your ears wiggle at the appropriate
amount for the soft body dynamics it's
like
i don't know you know like
you know for for animation of animals
and whatnot
people we've gotten really good over the
last you know 20 years doing that i
think mostly pioneered by weta
and whatnot i think actually andrew
kramer talked about this in the recent
episode about that
and it's like it all starts with like
animating the bone sched
like skeleton like the literal bones not
just like a digital representation like
actual
physically modeled you know everyone in
the audience probably took that
literally
except for you okay you're like oh i'm
used to working with digital skeletons
like not an actual like spooky bone
skeleton
really real quick if you think about it
all animators
are just digital taxidermists yeah
but okay so on top of those bones though
you uh you can't just like
download a 3d model and just animate it
and expect it to actually look
like that realistic of like a biological
being you have to actually
first off model the placement and
simulate how those
of all the muscles on a body and then
simulate how those muscles actually
expand when they contract because
it's got a certain amount of mass it
doesn't get shorter it contracts
and that means as it gets shorter it
actually gets wider
and so then you have to make sure you
get all your muscles across the chest
the back the neck
in in case of a face the dozens of
muscles or hundreds i don't know how
many muscles are in your face but a lot
right yeah yeah
and so once you simulate all of that
then you put a giant cloth over all of
it and
that's where your skin comes in because
the skin isn't just like moving up and
down it's actually sliding across that
muscle
and it's attached to certain points too
yeah yeah so you basically have to have
an entirely anatomically correct
3d model inside your little render
engine in order for it to look real and
then you got to make sure that your skin
shaders are good you got to make sure
that you got the right proper amount of
like subsurface scattering as the light
hits the skin
and goes through it and all that stuff
and guess what
we already can do all that just fine
like not we i mean like
the industry as a whole like ilm weta uh
lola like all these companies can
already do that
and yet it's still not at a hundred
percent
so what is missing well also i mean
it's crazy thing that through all those
technical things you described you still
have to match the likeness of somebody
also yeah no kidding right like starting
with their skull like what does their
skull look like because that's gonna
influence where the muscles go
like i mean this i think what we're
really just building up to here is we're
trying to explain
how hard and kind of why it's hard how
hard it is and why it's hard to build a
digital human being yeah
so that's actually led to a lot of
different approaches for example if you
look at
the matrix revolutions and the matrix
reloaded so they have all these agent
smith clones
and the situation you're dealing with
there is that you have to make a bunch
of digital heads but
you don't have to invent a head from
nothing
hugo weaving exists with his hair and
makeup and sunglasses
his cool sunglasses and his tuxedo
right there and you can scan them and
you can plop them off to the side i
guess it's not a tuxedo
all right all those fbi men in their
tuxedos
that's the cia man the spies get to wear
the tuxedos yeah um
so in that case what they did is they
basically filmed him with multiple
cameras
and he did the like emotions um and they
basically just did photogrammetry they
rebuilt each
each pose each frame of each pose in 3d
using multiple angles that are
recovering at the same time and they
just stuck those 3d models on top so all
the wrinkles all the dynamics all the
animation all the likeness
even the texture that's all captured
from hugo weaving himself you're
basically just getting 3d scans
and basically like a 3d photograph yep
exactly
which is insane to capture all that data
because us doing like
one photo scan takes about an hour to
process
all of that data and so to do like 24
frames per second
times how many seconds would just be
like an insane amount of data
are they are they actually doing that in
like a real-time thing sort of thing or
they just was not real time no
well i meant like let me rephrase uh
you're suggesting that they're actually
capturing
a frame every second from all those
cameras i thought you were going to say
that they just got
uh like destination poses no it was a
full motion performance
24 frames per second okay yeah i mean
that's that's pretty crazy
10 years ago yeah 40 terabytes per shot
40 terabytes per shot
18 years ago yeah
oh my god yeah so that's one way to do
it that's one way to do it
the nice thing is that your 3d model
looks perfect the downside
is that you are stuck having to just
simply replicate something you already
have yeah which is why it works so well
the other way to do it is kind of a
newer way
that it's a little complicated and i'm
not going to explain it perfectly
because i don't have my headphone
wrapped around it but basically it's how
ilm does a lot of their stuff these days
uh are you talking like the grand moff
tarkin and princess leia shots from
rogue one a little bit and then also the
irishman
yes okay yes okay so what they end up
doing is they uh because in that case
you are dealing with the 3d model of
something that doesn't exist
i mean i guess back in the day young
robert de niro existed but young robert
de niro does not exist right now
robert de niro is dead and to be fair
young robert de niro looks like 40 year
old robert de niro so
there's a certain point where they just
have to they can stop and they're good
enough
um but in this case you know so they
make the 3d model they get looking
as close as they can and then they
basically sculpt it into poses
and they're looking at reference of
robert de niro and you still have all
this references for scrape but you're
basically moving into different poses
and then you have an ai based pose
estimator
that will basically scan him like you'll
really record his face with once again
multiple cameras same way they did agent
smith
18 years ago record his face with
multiple cameras you basically get a 3d
model from that
but then the ai takes that and and it
uses its ai to pick out the perfect
pose match through all the different
combinations of like morphing and
warping the other face that's already
been built oh my goodness
real quick like that's a term that gets
thrown around pretty often and
we understand what it means in this
context but like just to quickly explain
what that means when you say
an ai does that what exactly does that
mean like
so we're talking so like let's say i
smile right
and you want a 3d model of my head
that's me when i'm like 100 years old
that's i'm
doing a time travel movie right and we
have digital niko's 100 years old
so somebody you know maybe scan my head
and then artist goes in and manipulates
it to look make it look like it's old
well okay so now they need to give it
some poses it's like they need to give
it a smile pose a blink pose a frown
pose you know like a mouth open you know
the e sound the a sound etc
so you have all these different poses
now the challenge becomes
if you want to derive those poses with
video
a computer needs to somehow take the
shapes of your face
and you know make that the shapes of the
other 3d face
now for something like your iphone if
you have an iphone you have animojis and
all that kind of stuff which is doing
just that
but that's basically just doing a basic
like if the mouth is wide
turn the smile slider up but that's not
how
human faces actually work like people
make their mouth go wide sometimes to
smile sometimes because they're about to
run into a wall at 100 miles an hour
like
there's a lot of reasons why you make
the shapes with your face that you do
um so running at 100 miles an hour the
shape is
[Laughter]
so the thing is um when they capture
these performances
they need to figure out what collection
of morph
shapes or basically poses will replicate
the shape that they're capturing
and a computer is just really good at
identifying that a computer's not
that good at identifying it with just
normal functions
it needs an ai to be like two percent
blink and
three percent smile and uh
you know ai stands for artificial
intelligence but like what what that
just means is that it's a program
that's been specifically trained trained
to do this so it's like all right
it's got the whole rocky uh routine
where you know drinks eggs
and runs upstairs and it's like at the
end of the day it's like all right
i am a program that is very good at
estimating poses
that's the only thing it can do yes
exactly and to get there it's you know
you train it through trial and error and
trial and error until it's like okay now
it's getting it figured out
and it's weird that with this new like
training process
before it's like aside from processing
things like you would ask a computer to
do something and it would just do it
instantly but now it has to actually
train like a person
over a long period of time and learn
which is just wild it's becoming more
human-like
it's super crazy and just because you
know computers have gotten
not just faster but um they have more
processing
you know more processors because we kind
of we hit the top level
speed of like one single processor more
or less you know
a little while ago it's still getting
better but not the rate it was but we
made up for it just by
putting a hundred of them on a chip yeah
no we have the thread ripper the amd
risen threadripper
okay the seat has 64 physical cores and
128 logical cores
jesus which like really took me by
surprise when i was working on i'm like
wait how many cores i want to use 128
cores
is that that's how i think it is like
the last time i the last time
i had that option my height my max level
was 16.
like they should be like 24 at most
yeah okay but so for the irishman and
whatnot
it all starts with a real human
performance right and so for you know
grand moff tarkin in rogue one
they put dots across the dude's face
right and then they just d
they had him actually do the performance
i forget the guy's name who uh was the
actor for that
and uh yeah he literally just did the
entire show uh
as himself with the rig uh capturing
his facial movements so that they can
actually
use that to animate the digital face
that they would then replace his whole
head with
but yeah as we were talking about that's
not quite enough and so
now all right deep fix actually can i
just point one thing there's a problem
that happens when you drive performances
with people's skills okay i know what
you're gonna say and this is absolutely
important i see it all the time
like for the longest time i've been
trying to put my finger on because we do
we analyze this stuff all the time on
vfx rs react and one of the challenges
that we face in the show is put into
words the problem that you're seeing
which at a certain point like if ilm has
done the shot
like how are you going to manage to put
into words
what they couldn't you know like how do
you break down the problem is and like
and that's a that's a huge challenge
when you get to the high level stuff but
there's this one thing like
about faces animated faces and they seem
kind of slidy and weird it's like how do
you describe it what's the problem and i
think it's
what we just said it's that they are
driving performance from the skin
but your face isn't driven from the skin
so like for example if i smile
you know and then you map that to
another 3d model it's going to pull the
lips back
kind of from the skin direction rather
than the muscles beneath tightening
and pulling the flesh up like a fleshy
curtain
you know into the corners of the stage
that is your smile kind of like
like like inverse kinematics but for
skin inverse skinematics
yes so i had never thought about that
that's so true
that's a really good point yeah it's
among once again among the
many other phenomena that are happening
when you move your facial muscles
you know like the one that always gets
me is from gemini man how would it talk
about
you know when you engage your muscles it
squeezes blood out of them and it
changes the color
and you can see that when people go like
this and then relax their forehead
you'll see the lines
yeah blood was squeezed out yeah without
that like
those are the things that you don't
realize until you do the whole shot like
it still doesn't look real
what's wrong with it and you're like oh
the blood should be pushed out of the
parts of the skin that are bunched up
from the muscles like
and it's like that's probably a pretty
easy fix it's probably just like a color
map that's generated from
like you know kind of like ambient
occlusion is just like these two
surfaces of the skin have gotten close
to each other
make that a little lighter and then have
like a timed release it's all probably
just done kind of similar to like wet
maps for instance yeah like
wet pieces of ground or surfaces
my point is that it it it's probably far
more complicated than this but i feel
like it's probably an easy solution
to a an unknown problem
oh okay okay now we can easily see all
these things to try to fix that and then
it's probably pretty hard but they it
was probably very achievable yeah
but you had to have somebody put their
finger on it exactly yeah us as humans
are so good at identifying when
something looks wrong but we're not
we're not that good at identifying what
looks wrong or why yeah so that takes us
to the mandalorian
first i think we should talk about what
makes a good one makes it bad
okay and and probably also how we think
they did it because i want to talk about
that because
dude i keep flip-flopping oh i you know
we okay so we shot this episode
of vfx artistry act what like two weeks
ago one week ago yeah like last week
yeah and this is by the time you guys
are all seeing this it's been like maybe
two weeks since we did that episode
and a few days since we recorded this uh
but toilet lost my train of thought with
that well
we don't know how they did it right yeah
so the disney has been
incredibly tight-lipped with how a lot
of that stuff is done
i follow several effects artists from
ilm and people who actually worked on
on stage at uh on on on the mandalorian
like the stagecraft stuff and the volume
and like they are all super tight-lipped
they're not allowed to talk about any of
this stuff
and so because of it there is no
information online about how they did it
there's a few things we do know for a
fact that they have
released we know that there was a
stand-in actor mark hamill was on set
but he was not the actual performer that
you see on screen
so there we do know that there was a
head replacement
and we also know history we also know
that the person who was
on uh who's performing had dots on their
face
and that's the kind of the extent of
what we know i
you know if it had been traditional cg
they
there's no reason they would keep that
secret that's so they've done that a
million times we do know
that disney does not want us to know
that there's something that they know
we also know that this summer this past
summer of 2020 disney released a
technical paper
on their own method of doing deep fakes
which has been which has since been
co-opted by the app face swap
do you mean their own method as in a
different like
kind of processing than the deep fix we
use or just like a different software
that
does the same thing it's a slightly
different process um and even the deep
fix software
i mean there's development that's gone
to the software but it's still just
based on the architecture
and the process of the very first deep
fake so i think it's more
of instead of like the difference
between like say after effects
and fusion like blackmagic fusion or
let's say
the difference between final cut pro and
premiere pro or microsoft word and
google docs
sure my point is that it's less that and
more the difference between
macintosh and windows yeah they're both
operating systems but the way they
are actually structured from the inside
are different interesting
yeah it's almost like it's it's the
realm of academics and research at this
point
because you're dealing with like well if
we approach an ai structure like this
with these kind of layers when we go
through this process we get this result
but if we do an ai structure like this
with these kind of layers and this
process to get rid of this result
that's what they're doing you know yeah
so so those are those are two different
deep fake things but so for the
mandalorian honestly my first like
analysis of that scene was that it
wasn't a deep fake interest and
i i kind of like kind of died on that
hill like i was like
like there are people on twitter who are
like i'm pretty sure it's a deep fake i
thought it was a deep fake and i was
like no it's definitely not a defeat i'm
with you now you will lose this bet sir
that is not a deep fake
and and so i've since learned that uh
and i've since agreed that we do think
it is a huge asterisk
deep fake yes but there is a lot more to
it than just that and i think that's
partly why i was misidentifying it
because it's not just a deep fake see
the first time i watched it i'm like oh
it's a deep fake
and then when i went back to watch i'm
like wait maybe it's not so you had the
opposite reaction
strange okay and i think part of us i
think all of us want to believe a little
bit that there's some sort of deep
fakery going on in it because
i think we're all tired of just another
cg head
being put on a body and getting us 95 of
the way there yeah like i i think we all
want to see something
brand new and inventive but
i think why ren changed why you changed
your mind rend
and why i changed my mind is that it's
actually both
and we talked about this in the vfx
react episode but we have since
studied that shot like and we still
don't know we still don't know
but we think so
let's talk about why it might be a deep
fake like what is it that makes it a
deep fake like why
why isn't it just a 3d model what makes
it different than the 3d model
ain't that the question well okay i mean
first i'm i
feel like i should explain why i think
it was a 3d model okay okay and it was
because like the head shape was
pretty good i was like okay that it's
mark hamill's head
and the animation was very very minimal
i think they learned their lesson from
like leia of like all right the more you
have him talk it's gonna
it's it's it's not gonna look and that
was what it was i was like wow the
talking just looks very
like keyframed yeah and i don't know
for me honestly it was the the skin
it just didn't quite look it didn't
quite have that
photo real rendering quality to me it
kind of looked it had a little bit more
of that
and again every time i go back and look
at it i changed my mind so it's hard for
me to say but at first it just kind of
looked a little too plasticky to me
and it made me also kind of wonder if
maybe it was an actual like 3d head
with a projection of luke's face onto it
that's what i kind of see the more i
look at it really okay
like a 2.5 d projection type thing yeah
like a 2.5 d projection type thing
because
the thing is this is for a show like
this isn't for movies for
for all intents and purposes a tv show
and to do
a digital a human not to mention luke
skywalker
as your digital human who has not been
in a movie
as young luke skywalker outside of the
briefest of flashbacks in like
40 years yeah you know one of the most
iconic characters in the world that has
been sitting there and everybody's been
trying to figure out how do i bring him
back
how to make some money off of luke
skywalker disney's like we're gonna take
a shot here
so like but to do this for a tv show is
pretty nuts
because any other situation you're
basically looking at spending millions
of dollars hiring teams
about probably at least 100 people to
get you a 3d model
that moves and looks and appears to be a
person
so to just go the 3d model route seems
completely impossible
just because it would require so much in
order just to get to a baseline
thing time consumption-wise yeah because
it's like for for rogue one
it's like this is a full-on
multi-hundred million dollar movie
you have a budget for that they probably
have a long time to work on it yeah like
two years yeah yeah
they probably had three weeks to do that
shot maybe four for mandalorian mm-hmm
again estimates we don't know that
submits but it could have been
a rush job it could have been something
that they actually have been working on
for the last six months
could be but i do know that they
basically had to turn around the whole
season in like a year
and with that in mind if you have eight
episodes i mean filming the thing is
probably gonna take 40 days
um so that's you know two months out of
your year almost gone right there
so now we got 10 months it's like then
you got to edit the whole thing get your
edit into a spot where it's kind of
locked like there's another two months
it pretty quickly boils down to you have
one month to the visual effects
um once again i could be totally wrong
maybe there's some more time there i'm
sure there's also research happening
but you still have to even have the
scripts written before you know what you
have to research
um but it puts you in an even tighter
spot you know not only do you not have
the budget of a movie you don't have the
time of a movie
so how do you create a digital human in
that time slavery slavery
no i'm playing i'm playing that's a bad
joke
um and i think that's i mean just like
how stagecraft was a
kind of a revolutionary thing that
helped them solve a problem that's where
i feel like deep fakes are that thing
but the 2.5 projection is almost the
same thing because
to me when i looked at it why i didn't
think it was a 3d model is the texture
it's like there's so much detail in the
picture of his face
yeah it looks photo realistic yeah now
either somebody sat there in photoshop
and made a single picture and they
projected it onto his face which is
very unlikely because it's so inflexible
because once again this is also a tv
show
they probably want a system a method
that works for more scenes you know
and this is just them starting with that
like
to get a 3d model looking that like that
but then to not have it be fully
animated doesn't make sense or even
fully lit
so this is the this is the other thing
though is that
when you look at the lighting like
outside of the texturing everything the
lighting is very smooth
it's like it doesn't quite match the
rest of the scene every like look at
grogu look at
the mandalorian like look at the
lighting and how much more harsh
lighting on everyone else
and he's it looks very soft it doesn't
even match his like robe really yeah
that was the kind of thing that that
made me is it felt like the brightness
values were off across his face versus
the rest of the shot like
his his robe was much darker yeah it
just kind of looked like his face was
just
lifted yeah and that could have been
like a color grading thing i don't know
it could have been but that's the thing
that's a flag that says hey i'm not a 3d
model
it's like a 3d model is like you want to
cast a shadow on a 3d model yeah you can
do it for days like we got shadows
galore they can be they can be the
sharpest the fuzziest it doesn't matter
shadows are easy reflections yeah you
can make them chrome if you want to
but like to do a 3d model then like not
light it at all
it's much more like a warpy image that's
once again it's like what's going on
here this does this isn't your average
3d thing
yeah so warping an image is also like
way too janky so there's got to be
something going on and just like when
you connect the dots of like
okay they've done deep fake research
trying to figure out it just it feels
like
it's a deep fake process but what they
did is recorded a dude
put a cg luke head on top of him and
then deep faked on the cg head to get
their deep fake
that's what it feels like that's what
kind of the sense that i get from it
which
also it makes sense like it does make
sense because
the main uh things that a cg luke
skywalker will lack will be detail
right and that's where a deep fake will
shine it'll bring back that detail you
know
the little folds in your eyelids and do
all those little the moles
on his on luke's face the little scar
you could achieve that with
texture work sure but if you have enough
time and effort you know time effort
what you probably won't be able to
achieve is the exact way that mark
hamill's eyelids fold when he drops his
eyebrows down
all the physics of the face yeah the way
the corners of his mouth curl when he
talks
and so we're saying that this cg head
would be animated the same way
like lola has been doing faces in the
past where it's probably simpler even
simpler like the iphone animoji's way
where it's you have some morph targets
and you have an ai analyze the footage
and apply those morph targets
to the 3d model i mean looking at the
show i think it's just an animator just
straight up like dialed in
yeah i mean those like the mouth going
from like closed to smiling or whatever
is
very smooth and uniform and it hits a
pose if you look at his mouth
like in frame by frame you'll see it hit
a pose each time
and the whole mouth hits it at the same
time and then changes directions at the
same time
interesting yeah yeah so that is why we
think it is that process so it's it's
3d head and then a deep fakes and then a
deep fake on top of that and so
and that's what we end up seeing but the
end result like
looks pretty good but it's still off
enough that people like
a lot of people i follow on twitter were
having like an adverse reaction to
they're like oh wow
like like my favorite reaction was jimmy
wong's reaction
he was like how come the dudes at south
park
did that sassy justice video and did
defects that look a million times better
than what disney is putting out in the
mandalorian like why why why
yeah how come nico is this a setup
i basically was like listen people
just assume excuse me
people just assume that
excuse me i need to yell once in a while
i get a lot of range
built up people just assume that
all of these vfx warehouses are already
at the forefront of technology research
when it comes to all this stuff and the
reality is that over the last couple
years that's not exactly the case
specifically when it comes to deep fakes
because
no one really knows how they're doing it
it's just a bunch of like white papers
online that
people with free time are like sure i'll
do this in my free time whereas you know
a studio
they have production workflows they have
a pipeline and they have
deadlines and budgets that they cannot
really
they don't have that much room to
maneuver and experiment they will
face legal action if they don't meet
their deadline yeah
yeah so it's like and and and so i don't
think people realize that deep fakes
aren't quite at a point
yet or at least they haven't been where
they can be easily implemented into the
workflow of a studio
proper yeah uh whereas deep voodoo
the company behind sassy justice which
you are affiliated with
they it's the only company on the planet
that is a deep fake specialized company
and they hired all of the deep fake
artists that are good
they like everyone on youtube that
you're like hey that guy made a cool
deep fake well chances are he probably
works at deep voodoo now
yeah you know and just just to talk
about deep voodoo for a second so last
year i had the opportunity of working
with
uh this new company that the south park
people started i called deep voodoo
effects
and the idea behind deep voodoo is for
them to i mean i don't want to put words
in their mouth but basically what they
have announced publicly is
the idea of the company is to basically
deliver the promise of you know deep
learning based visuals
um deepfix being an example of that uh
because the thing about ai and i mean
i'm i'm kind of using ai a little
inappropriately here
deep learning or machine learning is
what we're talking about here machine
learning is
when you boil down it's the computer
training it's trying something it fails
try something does a little bit better
try something does a little bit better
eventually it gets good
iterating yeah so i mean in a nutshell
it's machine learning
um a very tiny simplified nutshell
so the problem with with deep learning
though is that the system you build
it's you put something in and you get
something out you don't control the guts
because the
computer does that that's what the
training's for but in the world of like
film or heck even just in the world of
business like you need control you know
you don't
like let's say the director's like all
right i want a nice beautiful stormy sky
and the ai generates a perfect stormy
sky and the director's like
i want the cloud on the left and i was
like well i don't do that i just give
you what i give you and you have to deal
with it
that's the challenge with ai and that's
partially why it's just not everywhere
yet in visual effects or anything
i mean there's actually there's a bunch
of reasons but the deep
the deep voodoo guys and that company
know their goal is to tackle
this this process of being able to let
you use
you know or let you get cool visuals and
creative things
from deep learning machine consistently
yeah
and the thing that we focused on this
past year was uh was deep fakes
um so if you check out the sassy justice
youtube channel
you'll get to see some of that in action
um objectively some of the best deep
fakes released ever oh yeah
definitely that that the trump deep fake
sassy justice deep fake
there's nothing else like that out there
yeah and looks amazing and it's not just
say like it's like there's a
you know hey we have a secret secret
secret secret program you know it's like
it's people that know what they're doing
from the very start to the very end and
having worked it all out yeah because
they
have a lot of experience plus when you
guys are all working together you come
up with your own
sort of like methods to even make things
better yeah and
and so it's like that and that's why
yeah those artists are not working at
island they're not working at you know
pixelmundo or
mpc or lola
and so you know it really comes this is
a really good example of it really
depends on the person
rather than like the prestige of a team
you know it's like i'm sure that any
number of those people working at those
companies
if they sat down and actually just
started focusing on learning how to do
this
it could easily become a good deep fake
art oh yeah yeah totally nico's been
teaching me in the last week and i feel
like i
i'm like halfway there
yeah but also the challenge with defects
too is that there's no manual
there's no there's no history behind it
it's literally everything you're
learning you are figuring out
potentially for the first time on the
planet
but yeah um yeah the working with the
deep voodoo team was amazing though like
everybody there is incredible
and yeah looking at the mandalorian it's
like
but what if what if yeah speaking of
what if what
yeah what if we tried to do the
mandalorian
shot indeed what if we tried to do the
mandalorian shot
and made it better so
as i'm recording this podcast this is
tuesday
uh the day before the presidential
inauguration
uh 2021 that is the day of the week and
uh
this is coming out on thursday and the
deep fake stuff will be coming out over
the weekend we got vfx artists react
saturday
ideally if all goes to plan the crew
episode talking about all this stuff
comes out on sunday and that video is
where our time has been spent the last
week or two yes we've been setting out
to do our version of the mandalorian and
to try to do the hardest thing in visual
effects
and that's to replicate a human being
yes no okay now quick to point out
uh other people on youtube have already
deep faked
luke skywalker from the mandalorian
they've already done their own defeat on
that
what's the core problem with that though
nico the corp well the core problem with
it
look i don't wanna say there's a problem
with it look shamu if you're watching
this we're talking about you okay
i'm just saying like no there's nothing
like the core things that works already
yeah most of the work's already been
done that's
what it looks better the deep fake on
top of luke and mandalorian
looks so much better for most of it for
most of it
and there are bits where it falls apart
like the stiffness of the lips yes
when you look at the the performance it
goes from
what was already pretty cardboard and
stiff and stiff to just straight up it's
just stone face
it's like the lips move like a
millimeter those highlights are way
sharper oh yeah just the detail around
the eyelids looks better and
the lighting looks better like looks
more like a person but like we had we
saw the same thing with like princess
leia you know like ireland put
all of this money and effort into making
a uh a princess leia
from a new hope look photo real again
and it's like eh
but then someone threw a deep fake on it
with a you know like you see the media
sites like
oh guy fixed uh superman's mustache with
a 500
pc why couldn't they have done that it's
like well okay it's already pretty good
it's like most of the way there and then
when you throw a deep fake on top of it
it just makes it better
and i think by the third time they're
like all right we're gonna do cg luke
and no one's gonna tell us that
this time because we're deep thinking
ourselves and it's like well i defect
your deep fake and looks better
but it doesn't make the question it's
like okay if i didn't look better with
the deep fake why didn't they
do that that's a good question and when
when you think about why didn't they do
that it's maybe because
they don't really have much of a deep
faking team working on yeah maybe you
know it's like we are literally
literally literally on the frontier
of machine learning in visual effects
that stuff
doesn't exist yet but that is part of
what i really like about star wars
especially like mandalorian is that like
it is the the location for pushing
vfx boundaries seriously between this
the stagecraft
all of the the crazy you know things
that they had to pioneer for
for the show to be [ __ ] the volume
the freaking volume
i feel like people aren't psyched enough
about the volume really
yeah really yeah to be fair i feel like
everybody
in the industry is all like hey you
gotta follow me and we gotta have those
volumes around
okay okay i feel like i guess i'm just
i've just been talking to nico who is
very anti-volume
that's what i said about it i'm upset
about it no i'm not that i'm not
it's not anti-volume nico just can very
easily come across as very jaded about a
lot of things
and as soon as he's like tired of
hearing about something he's officially
jaded
and we've heard a lot about the volume
over the last year too because it's like
it has been
the biggest technology to come out in
filmmaking over the last couple decades
it's certainly the most exciting thing
in my opinion in my defense part of my
jadedness comes from the other dudes at
the studio here going hey let's build a
volume i'm like guys we don't need a
volume like no but we could do so many
cool things
like guys it's like gonna be so hard to
build a vault
none of us are actually saying we should
build a volume we know how much it costs
the stagecraft from
uh for mandalorian that's like a hundred
million dollar set
like we don't know here's my thing is we
only we just need one wall
just one wall just one we don't even
need a floor we just need one wall
with using our giant tv as a background
which is nothing new like we've been
able to do that for a while the thing
that sets the stagecraft apart is the
fact that the tv is bright
and it's large it's the brightness that
really matters because that's what
actually affects the lighting yeah this
would be like an hdr tv yeah well i mean
no
concert display panel yeah like it has
to actually be an led
light rather than just a lit pixel
i didn't i didn't know that yeah and the
density those led lights has to be high
enough they don't get any
better yeah just a couple years before
they started actually filming the
mandalorian the technology for the leds
wasn't quite there it was the leds
weren't dense enough and so what you
ended up with was that moire effect you
know anytime you take a picture
of your computer monitor and you get
like those weird rainbow lines that's
what they were getting
on their cinema cameras behind the
actors using the screens you have to be
far enough away to not get that
hey i mean we're putting our stuff on
youtube 1080p
lawless resolution all right with
rainbows in the background
deliver me a mandalorian season script
and i will get you the volume easy
easy the quality of those scripts
yeah yeah never mind um
okay but here's the thing we've been
working on something i think pretty big
these past two weeks yeah because when
you looked at that luke's shot it looked
good when it wasn't moving
but once it started moving it was super
stiff the lighting was very
static and flat and not really
physically accurate
and it's basically just like kind of
just having a picture there move around
a little bit
and you know what we know that we can
defect with skywalker i mean people
already know that people can deep fake
stuff
i'm sure people are like why don't they
just deep fake the scene that wouldn't
get us there
just keep faking the shot wouldn't get
us there i mean you could put a deep
fake on d pick but that's
great good job you had you had people's
blow millions of dollars getting you
that shot
and you put a deep fake on top and made
it two percent better and granted it's
better
but that's not the same thing that's
that's you just putting a filter on it
basically like we wanted to take it from
the ground up
and do the effect and try to do it how
we would approach it it's like pretend
we were sitting in their shoes yes all
right we are now the production team
going into filming the final episode of
the mandalorian we are both the onset
vfx supervisors shooting the shot and
the vfx
artist doing the shot yes how would we
have done it differently
granted we don't know how they did it
but this is how we would have done it
and we did it yes and the thing is
visual effects is still a magic trick
there's a lot of visual effects that
just work right
but a good visual effect is still a
magic trick and it's not something you
just do
after the fact it's something you do
in conjunction with the filmmakers in
conjunction with the story it's
you know the director shouldn't just
ever throw you the shot back yeah i put
an explosion in
that you're gonna get garbage and that's
honestly why a lot of vfx shots are
garbage
so in this case we had to think about
like from the very beginning
how are we going to film this to make it
look more real and not in the way that
they did it in the mandalorians like
we'll just have him stand still
and not move at all it's like no no that
how do we make it even
more life like how do we how do we
breathe vibrance into
luke skywalker and make him feel like
he's there well
answer number one lighting you know
this is a thing to talk about in drawing
if you draw something on a piece of
paper
put a shadow between the object and the
paper like let's say you're drawing a
sphere
you put a shadow blood sphere inside the
sphere is sitting on the paper it's
connected to the paper it's part of the
world
uh just like that song from aladdin or
whatever no little mermaid right
part of your world anyways
so it's the same thing with cg and we
talked about this a lot where like when
you have strong directional lighting
for your scene and it's hitting like a
cg object in the scene it brings the two
together because you have
you have lighting that unifies the whole
thing and so we we went back and we did
the scene and we did it with really
strong
side lighting um and what this does is
like
it gives you know lets you see all the
volume lets you see all the shape of
luke but
the deep fake also does a good job of
replicating that lighting
so it's playing to a strength of deep
fake plus just a strength of visual art
which is strong lighting binds the whole
scene together
but we didn't stop there because we had
our lighting
move and just like interactive lighting
starting with of course the lightsaber
and if you played video games and you're
into like graphics of video games
you'll notice how like static lighting
is kind of cool but once the light
starts moving through a scene the
shadows start moving and like you know
the surfaces kind of feel like they
change
you're like oh i like my grooves my
eyeballs like that
and so like you know what let's do that
too so the light sierra goes up by his
face
and then he turns it off and there's
sparks because he just you know there's
just big fights so like you know the
door is broken behind him so every once
in a while a big shower sparks comes
down and lights them up
and all this lighting suddenly
is like it's like flexing it's like
flexing your cds like oh yeah i got a cg
luke watch this i can put lights
wherever i want
on the left right the lights are just
spinning all over it's like wow it looks
really good while you're doing all that
it sure does
cg flex but yeah but everything from
like
you know having the lighting make his
face match his shoulders to having
lighting make the person in the
foreground match the background it
brings it all together and having it
move
makes it alive i think we forgot to talk
about
why they put a cg head on the stunt
double
oh you're right on the on the on this on
double the person who played who
performed as mark hamill
cover that real quick hmm you talk about
that right yeah so the reason being is
that
a nico you're always saying a deep fake
is just a mask
you could put a mask on someone and they
don't look like that person because
everything else other than the face
doesn't work right and what that means
is that
you know if the shape of the head is
wrong you could put a deep fake on
someone but the shape is still wrong
right and and so what they ended up
that's why we think they had to use a cg
head because the the person who was
performing
probably didn't have the same shape of
head as mark hamill so they had to
actually create that shape from scratch
by putting in mark hamill's head
digitally okay and then deep fake it
that being said having looked at a ton
of pictures of mark hamill's face doing
this defeat and then looking back at the
mandalorian shot
i don't know if they did that because
his jaw
looking right yeah i don't know what i
was noticing today when we were shooting
dean it was like
wait a minute that that still doesn't
look like mark hamill's head shape
it looks like they crossed mark hamill
with like a football dude
they probably want to make him feel a
little bit older i mean i think that's a
good description he does kind of look
like a crosstone mark hamilton football
dude
but i think they wanted to look a little
bit older but it's also not just
you know the head shape from the front
there's parts where benzo were to pick
up girl goo for example
a deep fake only does your face like
once i once you can't see my eyes and my
mouth like you're not in defect
territory anymore
or my ears and that's why we think that
whole shot was just a digi head yeah
that's
and why they probably just had a digital
head to begin with it also lets them
control the performance
you get into some things around you know
like mark hamill's not doing the
performance
is it okay for another dude to be doing
the performance or
or do we need to capture mark hamill's
performance aka filming with the camera
then have an animator sent you know
match the video to a cg head like
because i feel like that's what they did
and they are very careful about having
mark hamill involved every step of the
process so they don't
run into that weird territory they want
to make this this luke was played by
mark
they want to really make that clear and
so i i bet you it's a lot about the
messaging there
yeah it's you know he did the voice
which by the way was ai augmented
it was completely resynthesized yeah um
well there's a few lines where you can
hear it where it sounds like
google maps talking to you so they did
they you know he did the voice and they
enhanced that
and he probably did the performance he
probably did like literally did the
entire performance
and they've also probably had a face
capture with him not like four three not
with tracking markers per se but just a
performance capture
and they used all of that to inform the
performance and yeah there's a body
double there
but i don't you know his face probably
isn't driving the animation so that's
another reason why they'd have a cg head
because they can say that mark did the
performance yeah
and the reason why i bring that up is
because we are shooting with dean
yeah we chose dean because his face
structure is the closest out of all of
us to match
mark hamill he also loves star wars and
yeah he you know
this is his dream come true he's
literally he was born for this role
yes but yeah so we're like okay cool
problem solved right correct head shape
and then we shot it
and then we discovered oh yeah there's a
lot more to it than just head shape
it's the neck it's the shoulders the
posture the hair
the ears the ears yeah and we're like
wow that's mark hamill's face but what
is this monstrosity
it's like we thought we were on the
right track
so we had to redo the whole thing we
redid yeah but
we used that as an informative lesson
because we knew okay
so uh dean's neck is longer than mark
hamill's he's got
shoulders that kind of slope downwards
more than mark as well and so that we
essentially just kind of costumed him up
mm-hmm we added shoulder pads we uh we
got them
up we dolled them up yeah we got in the
queen's gambit
wig no no it was the julie andrews uh
sound of music
oh yes yes we got him a wig and we
styled it to look as closely as possible
to mark hamill's hair i'll shout out to
jordan for
yeah we literally spray painted the wig
by the way
yeah brown spray paint yeah because i
went in there i was like
is it possible to make it less like
clumpy and she's like yeah but every
time i comb it all the paint comes out
gotcha okay that's okay but okay so
that was our first lesson it was like
okay we got pretty close
through this whole time we are training
doing all the deep fake stuff in the
background
and getting a pretty solid model of luke
skywalker yeah
matching trained off of dean's face and
by the way the
30 90 is amazing
what an amazing gpu i have never gotten
a model with a million iterations before
really really wow but i did
on this project a million iterations
it's crazy
the keanu reeves one was like a hundred
and fifty thousand
yeah dang son that's the thing because
and that was at 128 pixels
i feel like we entered the scene of deep
fakes pretty early on
ish in the scope of things with the tom
cruise and
and uh keanu reeves videos but those
were two years ago
i know like dude looking back at that
tom cruise one
it's like oh baby
honestly looking back on the tom cruise
one i don't think is that good dude
but honestly props to you nico for
diving in head first
right when that stuff hard and
especially with the title we made
the world's best deep face at the time
nobody had done anything like it that is
true because it wasn't it was more than
just the deep fake visual
it was combining it with the performance
that was the special magic we brought to
the table with that yeah that's the
special magic brought to the table here
as well yeah
because luke's performance in my opinion
sorry if anybody who worked in
mandalorians listening to this but i
thought it was pretty
wooden and that's the thing number two
wooden
i was gonna say stone no it was it was
very stiff it was like
you can i definitely got the feeling
that everyone on set was like all right
you're playing we don't really know what
we're doing let's play this safer than
safe
yeah don't do anything just nod your
head like
[Music]
it is because if they hadn't done that
it would have been much better
well unless they unless they couldn't
handle the animation yeah that's
that's the risk you know is that like if
they did try to go a little bit more
and then they couldn't deliver they're
screwed it's like yeah what's the worst
thing that can happen
uh just not delivering the final effect
shots for the finale of disney's biggest
show in the world right now
yeah that's what's at stake the stakes
are high so play it safer than safe it's
a steakhouse it makes sense this is the
thing that we don't have to do at a
youtube studio
but they have to do okay but still you
just like okay last take
let's do one where you're more
expressive go and then you just have it
you're right peter but you know once you
get editing you still gotta commit to
the safer
yeah again we're still talking about
traditional workflows and pipelines and
it's like
yes we we have the youtube studio we
have we have let's just push the video
today we have luke skywalker giving the
tashi station line
and that is not something ilm or disney
would have ever put out
yeah so you know we have the lighting
but then defects handle performances
pretty well
so we're going harder on the performance
we're changing the angles on the head
he's looking around he's
moving a little bit like it's just we
are constantly demonstrating like hey
this isn't
flat this is real it moves it looks it
breathes it smiles it reacts there's
lights that shine on it
it's there it's real and then the crazy
thing about all this
is that at no point are we touching a 3d
model
it's all driven by a human being yeah
good classic makeup like we spent
more than an hour on that wig we spent
multiple hours tracking wigs down and
all that kind of stuff oh yeah
there wasn't hard work spent on our
computer that was hard work spent just
getting stuff looking good once again
shout out to jordan christian for all
that hard work
yeah it's like that's the theme of the
mandalorian is pre-production yeah the
whole
idea behind stagecraft is you have to do
all your vfx first
yeah you have to create your scenes you
have to create your environments and
textures and all that stuff and build it
out and then
you build out your set and then you film
it and then you're
done and then that's it
so yeah you know it's like defeat was a
part of this but also just
putting in the time to like get the
costume right and to get the wig right
to get the performance right to get the
lines right we
we had dean match the the cadence you
know so we can use the lines that are
already from the show
dean's a good actor by the way yeah he
did a great job performing and that's
the other crazy thing about all this
it's not just a performance it's a
puppet
yes okay i think i know where you're
about to go with this too yeah and this
is another thing that i think hollywood
really struggles with some actors
totally get this because some actors are
pros but other actors have different
ways they've learned some actors are not
pros
yeah but i think a lot of the people
that do work on like the big movies like
in the marvels and things like that i
think they understand this concept of
being a puppet
because that's kind of what you are
sometimes or you're the puppet master in
this case
the deep fake is being driven by the
puppet master the puppet master is dean
and he's using his face
to drive the puppet you know the mask
that is the deep fake
so for example luke his eyebrows don't
sit as low as dean's eyebrows do so if
dean relaxes his face it looks like luke
is kind of furrowing his brows
so dean needs to raise his eyebrows a
little bit to just look like a normal
neutral luke skywalker yeah so dean as
luke skywalker is walking around with a
mildly surprised look on his face just
to deliver
a look that is you know normal yeah
and that's that's a thing where like as
a performer and as an actor
you need to be able to do these things
and then set that like calibrate that as
your neutral point
and then act on top of that and once
again this is something we learned from
basically
shooting it going the process and going
huh
he looks angry yeah he looks creepy he's
stealing that baby i don't know what
he's gonna do with it exactly
also we learned that uh when you give
luke uh
dean's jawline he turns to henry cavill
oh plus the plus the brow furrow just
over the brow furrow that's exactly
henry cavill i think it's the
the champion yeah
um so like having dean not just do a
performance you know just go out there
i'm just luke skywalker and doing his
thing like
but having him drive the mask as a
puppet master knowing that he has to
raise his eyebrows more as a neutral
pose than the things he does from there
changes the expression his smiles need
to be bigger than usual
mark hamill doesn't show that his top
row of teeth very often
he smiles and like expresses with his
bottom row like never
yeah and dean is the opposite so we have
some really weird looking deep fakes
where dean smiles and then like
it's mark campbell smiling and you're
like baby teeth
let's see where all these teeth come
from because that's that's the crazy
thing about a deep fake is that
if an image for a pose hasn't ever been
captured it cannot generate it
exactly it can only generate what it's
already seen and so because
there's no images of mark hamill smiling
with his top teeth
when you're trying to make a deep fake
mark hamill smile with his top
top teeth the deep fake uh ai doesn't
really know what to do it's like okay
um how about this here's some teeth
because it did all the pre-training on
just a whole bunch of human faces
but they're not mark hamill's teeth so
it ends up kind of looking like
a little monster-ish yeah you get some
weird
horrible stuff from the training i was
doing i was definitely seeing any time
we were looking up
his face like looking if you could see
both nostrils it was just like
burn victim fake that being said have
you seen it recently
because in the last over the weekend it
fully figured those out and it
definitely looks jankier but we have the
on my angles like those scenarios really
on the one on my computer it's it's
pretty darn good
yeah okay so progress report uh we
shot we re-shot dean today with updated
wig
updated costume data performance uh
all that stuff and you've already run
a single export of a deep fake over the
top of that yes literally
right we were late to this podcast
because we were seeing the results of it
for the first time
yeah and what that means is that it's
not been trained on that yet we haven't
done any compositing either no magic
it's literally like all right
here's some new inputs export now no
training no time
just export what you got and
it looked pretty dang good it looks
pretty dang good
even it's super rough it's got a lot of
rough edges to it but even that is just
like oh my god like yeah
we might actually do it we might
actually do it that's the crazy thing is
like we might
actually do it i think we are managing
to deliver a shot
that when he takes his hood off people
go like holy cow
that's luke skywalker yeah and the scene
continues it's just
he's here he's real he's in the scene
performing
and there's no weirdness about it
there's no lips moving weird there's no
3d rendering incorrectly there's no
lighting
acting up it's just natural and nothing
inside of me outside of my brain knowing
that luke can't be there
is telling me that it's wrong i mean
yeah it's still not at a hundred percent
yet
not at 100 yet but it's it's the the
potential is so obvious that it's just
like wow
like when we started off this whole
project like we threw around title ideas
of like
we did luke skywalker better than disney
and it's like you know the clickbait
type thing there and
at the at the same time i'm like ah but
like prob we probably won't though we'll
probably
get like kind of close but like it's
probably not going to actually be better
but after seeing today i'm like well
crap i mean it's kind of better
it's kind of better and like that's
that's thing too is like you know
there's like the youtuber edge on things
like oh
disney oh my shot's better i need to use
a 500 computer like
yeah no disrespect to the people who
worked super hard on this stuff
like all these people who spent hours
and hours yeah but the thing is like you
know now that
like you know i we're all we try to be
respectful like because
that world is so tough and there's so
much going on like
i'm not gonna get into it here but like
so just like oh we're gonna make a
better like it's like no you're not
like even if it looks better visually
like you have no idea the constraints
they had like there's no way you can
deliver what they delivered in the
amount of time they had
they're still better because they're the
pros they're the pros
but that being said results
speak for themselves yes it's it's an
explicit like
objective result that we are going to
deliver to the internet and
we'll see what the internet just just
the the incomplete stuff i was seeing
today i was
i was kind of blown away like i was like
okay
all right um title this video whatever
you want now
okay fine yeah it just seems it's so
arrogant when we when we kind of like
call it like that but at the same time
it's like if you can back it up and it's
that kind of title that gets views it's
like
yeah i don't know wait what is it
arrogance is confidence without proof
but we got proof
yeah i mean subjective proof we haven't
we haven't i mean
sam's first reaction was like oh that
looks fake
that was literally his first reaction
after all of us were like wow this looks
so good and sam's like ooh
i thought you would just pull yank in
our chain man i mean maybe
maybe i'm just trying to keep our heads
from getting too high in those clouds
whatever makes you sleep at night niko
or was it just a play on
the word deep fake i mean maybe i don't
know uh
yeah that being said we are now
currently full on
in effects mode now uh clint's kicking
out some keyed out shots because we shot
dean against a
whole another weird story it was a green
screen
blues screen we lit a green screen with
blue lights to make it a blue screen
the official term is grew screen
screen screen yeah
yeah that's that's a whole other thing i
don't know how much we talked about that
in the video but
yeah anyway we just took a green screen
and blasted it with
blue light so now it's a blue screen but
it worked so well
it worked really well really well the
idea is that we don't have a blue screen
but he's got a green lightsaber he can't
just have a green lightsaber on a green
screen
so let's light the green screen with
blue light
yeah because about while back i can't
remember who was might be carmichael we
were lighting a green screen he's like
you turn the light to green i'm like
wait our lights can do any color now and
you just made the light green so
a green screen is more green genius you
don't need any other colors in the green
screen
why would you ever use any other colors
and it makes it way easier to key out
yeah but then there's the whole like oh
no we need a blue screen
but what if if you only provided the
blue spectrum
of light yeah and and shooting it that
way
created a lot of blue lights and a lot
of blue spill and that overall
influenced the final shot
a lot more because you once you're done
with the green screen sorry once you're
done with the the lightsaber
you turned off the blue light and went
back to the stock green screen
and that was when i was like that
doesn't look good at all i was like it's
just
it's i mean yeah it's on a green screen
but like the lighting is all different
yeah and it's because you're actually
lighting the scene differently mm-hmm
yeah cause all the luke skywalker deep
fakes you know they're trained from
the images from return of the jedi in
this case and
the movie is either shot outdoors and
daylight's kind of bluish
or shot at night time with blue lights
there isn't a lot of luke skywalker shot
with green lights but there's a lot of
luke skywalker shot with blue lights or
at least slightly blue lights
so even if the blue is like a little
spill suppressed out like you still have
that influence on the skin tone
and it just the deep egg looked better
with that blue influence versus the
green influence
yeah so that's i guess our final step
here is we're actually compositing in
a different background with the stuff
that we shot of dean
and we're making final vfx shots as if
dean is the new actor playing
luke skywalker not mark hamill and so
then that's that's our final shot
and that's what we're taking to actually
run through the deep fake our final once
all the training is done we're going to
train it on
those final composited shots yes and why
is that niko
because the deep fake you know it
doesn't exist in the world
of floating point and high bit depth
this and that and you know raw imagery
it's just
you're gonna give it color and it's
gonna give you the face a different face
same colors boom that's it so we want to
do that at the end once we have all our
colors locked in
just do the face swap then done because
the uh the keying process where you take
out the green screen
it changes some of the colors yeah cause
you'll have the spill suppression it's
gonna mute the blues or mute the greens
where you get some of the green lighting
on the edge of the actor you have to do
a process to remove that
so it influences the colors yeah yeah
which is a really tricky thing about
green screens and blue screens is that
you end up with a green and blue light
hitting your actor and
it's not particularly pretty and then
you have edges that
you know if you have hair you're trying
to key out all that stuff yeah
i'm suddenly shifting this back to a
volume yeah
if only we had an led wall you know what
guys
i'm gonna somehow make an ai that can do
green screen keying
smartly and then we want to worry about
this anymore but will it
put the lighting from the surrounding
set on the actor
you know in the world of a.i that might
be entirely possible
awesome i'm all for it i think
all of this stuff this ai talk deep
learning machine
uh neural nets all this stuff i think i
said some words out of order there
but the neural nets this is evolving
far more rapidly than i think most
people realize
yeah this is evolving at a really fast
rate
an exponential rate and i don't think
people fully recognize
that rate yeah i think we're just
realizing
in a very limited slice of our life you
know here's a deep fake and it's like
whoa this is game changing for us not
just because i can go and make a
character like to just realize a digital
human
so well and in a way that doesn't
involve 3d animation or even really
a ton of input from the creator like it
just does it
dude if you want some existential dread
don't watch black mirror watch
two minute papers yeah dude oh man the
dolly
ai yeah we're gonna hit a point here
we this is another podcast for another
time but yeah
we should talk about ai in vfx in
general
which happens to be the next corridor
crew video
also fancy yeah
using uh using ai tools for vfx it's
kind of a new
nude thing the dude who played i forget
his name
he was the lead actor in ready player
one do you remember his name
oh no oh i know it i it's right in my
tongue i wanna say his name was like ty
or something like that yeah yeah yeah
ty sheridan that's him yeah okay he
started a vfx company
primarily using iai tools what him the
actor
yeah epic right that's pretty sweet i
forget that i
literally forget all of the important
details that's awesome uh yeah it's like
him and some partners
are just trying to leverage uh the
evolving ai landscape of
computer generated vfx tools wow and
he's got a vfx company now that's really
cool yeah
i thought that was really cool uh but
that that's about all i know about that
the tricky thing is making a company
that leverages ai
for like non-ai things before the
pendulum swings so far that just ai does
the entire thing
yeah it's like i'll have ai to do my
rotoscoping it's like you know you can
just ai can make the whole scene right
it's like uh
okay yeah i'll do that you know i can
just make the whole movie though right
oh yeah i guess i don't need that that
thing that doesn't say i'll just have to
make some you know a i made movies
obsolete and you just live within
another reality right it's like
oh yeah [ __ ] i can definitely foresee in
the future like i don't know how many
years out it's whatever many years you
think it's going to be it's going to be
less
but it's at some point we're going to
have a
stamp of pride that this was made by
humans oh man
this script was written by a person
the person who did this effect was a
person
yeah you know you talk to people and
it's like yeah but the ai will never
replicate the human spirit you know it's
like i don't know man
human spirit is pretty replicatable
not to mention just ai assisted
everything it's like writing a script
like what should happen next like well
if you look at all the other scripts
i've
been written um here's the three best
ideas you could do it's like oh
i'll do that one right next to that
what's this character's name it's like
well if you look at all the stories that
are written uh here's the best three
names for this moment it's like
that's a good one actually yeah no
that's that's the idea behind generative
design
i know i'm starting to go off on a new
tangent here at the end of this podcast
but
uh generative design is the idea in like
cad modeling you say you got to design a
structure or a chair for instance
you just input like some constraints
like okay it must
have four points of contact with the
ground and it must hold this much weight
at this height
and then it literally designs thousands
of
models with different kind of
constraints and all like you end up with
these really weird organic
shapes just to design a chair and you go
through and it's like okay
all of these ones not really what i'm
looking for i'm looking more at like
these and then it takes those and it
expands
another thousand just off of those few
designs and you slowly just start like
picking and choosing until you iterate
like literally
hundreds of thousands of different
designs to choose just the one that you
want to pick so it's like when you use
that google images trick where you like
google image search one thing and then
you look at the visually
similar images and you go to that and
then you just keep doing it until you
find what you want
yeah it's pretty alternative design it's
it's a brand new style
that's an i thing too right yeah i mean
all the negative
stuff is ai driven also it's the exact
same thing wild
yeah how many bicycles are in these
pictures
that's that's the other thing we are
training every time you log into our
website
if you're training the internet look a
little a little story here to wrap up
this podcast okay this will be the last
thing all right so i get hit with one of
those capture things right
identify the parking meters so somebody
took a bunch of pictures in this
neighborhood that had mailboxes
that kind of looked like parking meters
but they're clearly mailboxes
well apparently most people aren't
spending any time looking at the
pictures because it wouldn't let me
continue
until i clicked on a dang mailbox to
tell us that it was a parking meter
really i was like that's not a parking
meter it's like you need to click on it
otherwise you're not a human it's like
man you've had a lot of people who are
lazy just click on your captures
like this is not a parking view that
looks like oh my goodness it's like wow
i had to
have to betray the ai like that's a
that's a mailbox so if some point
2050 to a parking spot in front of a
mailbox they're like please pay for your
parking that's exactly what's going to
or honestly i mean that's probably the
stuff like when you drive the tesla and
like
the tesla sees things that it's ai i
mean that's probably like
one of the sources they pull their data
from yeah so yeah same thing
yeah you'll see a little parking meter
icon pop up in your next
mailbox yeah that's where human judgment
will still be a
a pretty strong force for the
foreseeable future even in spite of all
the
the ai advancements it's like at the end
of the day
you know an ai can be incredibly well
trained and incredibly uh capable but
it still will not have a broad macro
sense of
judgment yeah as far as for a while
it'll eventually get there
it'll eventually get there but that's
general ai and now we're talking like
freaking what's the the the ultimatum
thing the
singularity singularity yeah yeah but
that's that's a podcast
for another time until then enjoy the
luke skywalker deep fake when it comes
out
so excited for this oh my god this is
like this is a big deal it's gonna be
fun
yeah all right thanks for watching
everyone
thanks for listening on all of your
different uh platforms of choice
if you're new to the podcast please
consider subscribing it's also pretty
much
everywhere that you can listen to
podcasts spotify etc you know
go check it out follow corridor digital
on etsy
um but now we have to make an etsy
account on first class
because otherwise someone else is going
to make it you know on network
television if they said a website name
and the website didn't exist they had
like they had to they had to make it
make it yeah you could just say a
website
without the website being yours or
whatever it's just a weird rule but it
kind of makes sense
anyway yeah thanks for hopefully see you
watching
in another podcast soon